and we're going to begin with this the
Trump administration proposing a
controversial new rule that would allow
faith-based adoption and foster
organizations to deny their services to
LGBTQ couples this would be a rollback
of a 2016 move by the Obama
administration many religious groups
support the change but critics say it's
a license for discrimination Jan
Crawford is in Washington Jam good
morning so tell us more about the
reaction to this I mean gay rights
groups say there's tens of thousands of
foster children awaiting adoption and
the rule would make even fewer families
available to them but the White House
maintains this isn't about preventing
the LGBTQ community from adopting it's
about protecting religious organizations
from having to choose between helping
children and honoring their faith it was
the most incredible gift that I could
have received and just want to give that
to someone else as someone who has
adopted Kerry Ann Hamilton always knew
she would do the same when it came time
to expand her family she and her partner
LJ are in the early stages of the
process but a proposed rule by the
Department of Health and Human Services
would allow foster care and adoption
agencies to reject LGBTQ families on
religious grounds the move would also
apply to other programs receiving
federal grants including those that help
with HIV prevention or homelessness what
this role does is it eliminates the
number of willing and loving and safe
families for children who are in need of
homes and that to me is very troubling
proponents of the new rule dispute that
claim Travis Webber is with the Family
Research Council a Christian advocacy
group this really just allows a bigger
pool of organizations and parents who
would we could pick from an organization
that aligns with their own beliefs and
philosophy on the family and on where a
child should be placed in a statement
the family equality council an advocacy
group for LGBTQ families said the rule
will further limit the pool of loving
homes available to America's four
hundred and forty thousand children
living in foster
and puts providers interest in
discriminating over the needs of youth
in care it's really unfair to call
someone's long held religious beliefs to
classify that it's discrimination it's
very important that these organizations
have the ability to place these children
and still operate according to their
convictions a 2018 study from UCLA found
an estimated a hundred and fourteen
thousand same-sex couples were raising
children in the US and 2016 the report
showed that same-sex couples are more
likely than different sex couples to be
raising adopted children I think this
issue is really bigger than politics
this is about children and we are
supposed to protect these children not
implement roles that hurt them now the
proposed rule could reportedly be
published in the Federal Register as
early as today and that would be
followed by a 30-day comment period
Gayle boy I hope they can work something
out there thank you very much Jann